what would you do if you were given
absolute power would you use it to fix
the world's ills or would you use it to
satisfy your own darkest desires
it's question we've seen answered again
and again in history but never so
conclusively as in the reign of Rome's
third emperor Gaius Julius Caesar
Germanicus or as you know him Caligula
[Music]
born into a powerful military family
Caligula rose up to become the most
infamous
emperor in Roman history during his
four-year reign he indulged in so much
excess that 2,000 years later his name
is still a byword for cruelty and
perversion you probably know that tales
about Caligula seducing his sister and
making his horse consul you may not know
though that the rest of his life was if
anything even wilder today we're gonna
take you inside the twisted world of
Rome's maddest emperor
when Gaius Julius Caesar Germanicus was
born on August the 31st 12a dia was into
a world of privilege that would have
made the average woman's head spin
Gaza's father was the general Germanicus
military hero of the empire
his mother Agrippa the elder came from a
family that had once been in line to the
imperial throne
school the family elite somewhat
undersell it they were like if the
Kennedys the Rothschilds the
Rockefellers and the Queen of England
had all joined into one single family
unit still Germanicus was a working
general and for little Gaius that meant
a childhood growing up in military camps
on the western frontier along the Rhine
when stationed in these camps guys was
given a small soldiers uniform to wear
the sight of this toddler for raiding
around it tickled the soldiers serving
and Germanic as so much that they gave
him the nickname little boot or to
render it in Latin Caligula
but while life may have seemed sweet
Ferb little Caligula on the frontier in
Rome an almighty storm was brewing for
nearly four decades the imperial throne
had been in the hands of Augustus but
with the first citizen now nearing the
end of his life
dark political forces they were
beginning to stir Augustus's plan had
been for one of atropine a--'s two
brothers to inherit his throne but both
of them had died young after falling out
with a third successor august's was
forced to turn to a sullen general
called Tiberius Tiberius was technically
a hero of the Empire but he was also
something of a colossal dick nobody
liked him not even or justice the only
way that the dying emperor could get
Tiberius on the throne without a riot
was the force Tiberius to adopt
Caligula's dad's the beloved Germanicus
that way everyone could sleep soundly
knowing that however terrible Tiberius
was Germanicus would soon be in charge
so you probably know the phrase the best
laid plans of mice and men
well Tiberius was about to do to
Augustus as plans exactly what Jerry
does to Tom with a stick of dynamite on
always the 1914 ad or Gustus shuffled
off this mortal coil no sooner was he
gone than Tiberius began moving against
Germanicus kanigan his family they were
taken from the Rhine and transplanted to
Syria there on October the 10th and 1980
dramatic has died and a miss
Arius circumstances convinced Tiberius
had poisoned her husband Agri Pina
agitated for justice it was at this
point that Tiberius brought the other
boot crashing down Tiberius forbid Agri
Pina to remarry and he exiled her to a
remote islands further her eldest two
sons were also in prison one of them
committed suicide the other staff to
death for Caligula it was a
life-changing upheaval although his
grandmother shielded him from Tiberius
as wrath he was suddenly left without
parents without brothers without hope
his only consolation may have been that
his three sisters were also allowed to
live certainly the experience it had
made them close so close in fact there
was often rumored that Caligula was
sleeping with the youngest Giulio
Drusilla but Tiberius he wasn't just
cunning he was also cruel in AD 31 or 32
the 19 year old Caligula was suddenly
summoned to Tiberius as villa on the
island of Capri from now on the Emperor
informed him he would have to live
alongside the man who destroyed his
family it was a bizarre verted thing for
Tiberius to do it would also be a
catastrophe for the entire Empire
[Music]
there's a couple of things you should
know about Tiberius the first is that
Tiberius was basically a Roman version
of Stalin he ruled through fear
instigating a wave of treason trials in
which people were convicted by kangaroo
courts executed and their bodies were
dumped in the river Tiber the second is
that he did all of this while staying
away from Rome itself in AD 26 the old
despot retreated to a villa on Capri
where he had a good time while a flunky
did all of the actual repressing
incidentally a good time for Tiberius
generally meant everyone else having an
extremely bad time if we can believe the
surviving sources Tiberius as time on
Capri was past satisfying himself with
underage boys and girls and then having
them hold off cliffs to their deaths oh
and he also liked to have the odd person
publicly tortured because I guess why
not and so it was into this world that
Caligula was summoned it's impossible to
say why Tiberius called Caligula to him
maybe it was just a sick game Tiberius
his flunkies would often question the
boy about his dead family goading him to
lash out but Caligula he wasn't stupid
he kept his mouth shut and deferred to
Tiberius more like his servants than an
adopted family member
sewed up areas he never got around to
killing the boy not don't need that he
seems to have rather grown to like him
before longtime arias was allowing
Caligula to indulge in orgies of his own
he was allowed to arrange and watch
sadistic tortures at his own leisure it
is said that after seeing how much the
quiet Caligula enjoyed watching others
suffer Tiberius remarked I'm nursing a
viper for the Roman people if he really
believed that though Tiberius he didn't
show it at some point in the mid 30s a.d
Tiberius named Caligula and Caligula's
cousin gemellus as joint heirs to the
Empire maybe if Tiberius knew what the
quiet young man had been up to on Capri
he would have been more cautious
Caligula later claims he likes to get up
in the dead of night and creep into
Tiberius his bedroom where he would hold
a dagger over the old man ready to
plunge it in only the voice of the Dead
or Gustus stopped him from doing this
deed less Looney Toons Caligula also
worked behind the scenes to forge an
alliance with the powerful Praetorian
Guard prefect nervious sutorius macro
when the time came Caligula wanted the
guard on his side
and that time came on March the 1637 ad
that morning word went out the Tiberius
had died in his sleep
Rome's tyrant Emperor was finally dead
there are a few theories about how type
areas died and one prominent one is that
Caligula suffocated the old man with a
pillow but even if this is just later
writers adding narrative spice to the
tale the result it was the same in Rome
the people they went nuts they demanded
Tiberius this body be dragged through
the streets and hurled into the river as
all those who had been executed at his
trials had had done to them while Rome
was busy partying out on Capri Caligula
was putting his plan into motion with
Tiberius Khan the Praetorian Guard came
out for Caligula jameelah's was based
under house arrest and he never tasted
freedom again his rival imprisoned
Caligula road to Rome and presented
himself to the people as their new
emperor and this it wasn't actually as
hard as he might think people that hated
Tiberius the whole city it was seriously
pumped that he was gone and now they
were being told that his replacement
would be the son of their beloved
general Germanicus they liked that
to paraphrase Philip J fry Rome was
basically just like shut up and take our
throne aged only 24 Caligula was
elevated to undisputed ruler of the
empire the people they were ecstatic as
he rode into the city they lined up and
screams like he was Roman Elvis oh it
would not be long though before Caligula
was making those same citizens scream
but for very different reasons so this
is it right the part where we finally
get into all of the juicy stories about
Caligula promoting his horse and
marrying his sister oh well make that
still all bitter ways down the road
because here's the thing about Caligula
the mad emperor when he first sees power
he was seen as Caligula the emperor that
everyone just couldn't get enough of
seriously Caligula 1.0 was like
everything Rome had ever dreamed of he
entered Tiberius as treason trials he
restored confiscated property he eased
up on persecution he lowered taxes he
gave the army a pay rise as if this
wasn't enough Caligula also through
endless gladiator games and feasts to
celebrate his rise to power imagine if
you're an ordinary Roman for over twenty
years you've been living in a state of
fear under a tyrant you could have you
killed
anytime and now there's a new guy in
town and he's given you bread and
circuses and a promise that he's not
gonna kill you at random it's pretty
good times as 3780 rolls on people dare
to hope that maybe this was it
maybe Tiberius had been a one-off and
all the Emperor's were gonna be good
from now on
but ya know that October Caligula
suddenly took sick it was possible he
was poisoned at any rate he spent the
best part of a month floating on the
threshold between life and death the
people of Rome they were appalled
they couldn't lose their shiny new
emperor there was weeping in the streets
in the Senate senators took turns to
stand up and beseech the gods to spare
Caligula anvil even begged Jupiter to
take them in this place miraculously
these prayers worked Caligula recovered
dragging his weakened body back to the
land of the living if this was a horror
movie this would be the point where
would say however it seemed he brought
some evil spirits back with him since
this is history they will simply say
Caligula came back a changed man the
popular Emperor was gone in his place
with something much much darker not long
after recovering Caligula invited the
Senators who prayed for his life to come
and visit him there he thanks them for
asking Jupiter to take them in his place
very ask them when they were going to do
it no record exists of the conversation
that followed but it likely went
something like this
your highness ask the Senators rather
puzzled you know it replied Caligula you
ask the gods to let you die so I may
live well I am alive so I repeat when
are you going to die the Senators at no
choice one by one they were all forced
to commit suicide it was the first sign
of the madness that was about to consume
the entire empire now we do need to be a
bit careful here because plenty of
ancient and contemporary writers like to
use Caligula sickness as a
transformative events like he was a
saint before and devil after but we've
already seen Caligula getting his rocks
off torturing people and Tiberius as
Villa we've also seen him quietly
dispose of his rival to the throne and
scheme his way to power so yeah can I
became a monster after his illness but
it's not like the signs weren't already
there where the Senators dared Caligula
returns public life from the get-go it
was clear that something was rather
wrong he ditched the robes and he
started dressing in outlandish costumes
sometimes including in women's clothes
he claims that he was plagued by endless
headaches
you can always imagine the people of
Rome giving one another slide long
glances and wondering what happens to
their fun Emperor
well Caligula he still wanted to have
his fun and Rome was about to discover
that Caligula's definition of fun was
even more terrifying than Tiberius
[Music]
[Applause]
now before we go any further there's
something you need to understand about
this period in Roman history so many
sources have been lost over the years
that we have barely any contemporary
accounts of Caligula the information we
do have on his life generally comes from
Suetonius book on the Emperor's and
Kassius Diaz biography of Caligula both
they're not exactly great historians and
they lived a long time after Caligula
had died with do not even being born
into 120 odd years after Caligula's
death to put it another way expecting
you know these guys to give a pinpoint
accurate account of Caligula's reign is
like expecting someone born this very
year to give an eyewitness account to
the life of otto von bismarck that being
said there's likely a kernel of truth in
there otherwise suspect accounts and
even a kernel would be enough to rank
Caligula as one of the maddest rulers in
history it's said the post illness
Caligula liked to humiliate the Senate
senators would be made to run alongside
his carriage for miles at a time through
the streets of Rome those that refused
would be humiliated in other ways
Caligula would throw dinner parties for
the Senators and their wives
midway through the meal had pick a wife
he liked the look of take her into a
back room and force himself on her and
then return her to her husband who'd be
forced to act like nothing had happened
speaking of women Caligula sexual
appetites were both enormous and
enormous leak ruled in AD 37 or 38 for
example he went to the wedding of gasps
Calpurnia's piso and nevere erst Elia
the emperor was so taken with Livia that
he ordered her to marry him instead she
did and yet his way with her then he
divorced her the next morning there's a
final kicker he forbade her to
ever married Gaius Livia wasn't the only
one Lelaina Polina was also forced to
divorce her husband to marry Caligula I
need to be ditched after Benny six
months then there are the other rumours
that Caligula slept with everyone from
whores to young boys to the male Ataman
ester but the most famous affair
Caligula had was of course with his
sister remember Julia Drusilla who we
mentioned back at the start of the video
he mentioned there was rumored that
Caligula was sleeping with her well once
he became Emperor Caligula seems to have
gone out of his way to confirm those
rumours Drusilla was elevated to the
status of Emperor's wife the army was
required to take a loyalty oath to her
and the two were never apart when
Drusilla died in June of 38 AD the
heartbroken Caligula had declared her a
goddess and forced people to worship her
even with this weird relationship though
much of what you may have heard is
untrue that shocking scene in I Claudius
where Caligula eats the fetus torn from
Drucilla's body we're extremely pleased
to tell you that that was pure fiction
still Caligula's cruelty and his
insanity they were becoming pretty hard
to ignore
kasia's dear has it that the Emperor
practiced pulling terrified facial
expressions purely to put the fear of
God into his subjects at one part he
allegedly burst out laughing when guests
asked what was funny Caligula replied
I've just thought that I'm ready to give
the word and you all have your throats
cut hilarious but it was more than just
an idle threat
in AD 38 Caligula finally ordered
gemellus executed incredibly he had
macro the Praetorian Guard prefect you'd
help him seize power executed shortly
after it was Caligula's first major
taste of blood and apparently he liked
it enough to go back for more
throughout all this the fun pre illness
Emperor hadn't completely vanished for
all his bad rap Caligula did do some
good stuff he extended Rome's aqueduct
network bringing clean drinking water to
many parts of the city he had new ports
constructed opening the Empire to more
trade
there's also reason to believe some of
the more infamous stories about him
they're just false that all thing about
making a sauce a consul it's thought
Caligula was probably insulting a
senator's intelligence and made a
comment to the effect of you're so
useless
I might as well make my horse console
which later writers took rather
literally on the other hand though it's
quite possible that the tale of the bay
of bali is true if you're not heard of
this it's claims that Caligula
discovered an orb prophecy by an
astrologer that said Caligula had no
more chance of becoming Emperor than of
riding a horse across the bay of Bali
once he became Emperor Caligula
requisitioned boats from across Italy
moored them together and turns them into
a two or three mile bridge across the
bay he then spent two whole days riding
up and down the longest in triumph so
many boats were put out of action for
this that Rome suffered a green shortage
far as they are though tales like this
often conceal Caligula's truly dark
nature in 1839 the Treasury was empty
too much money had been spent funding
Caligula's lavish lifestyle so Caligula
pulled a fast one he reinstated diuresis
treason trials and now they would be
even crueler than before people were
selected from Roman society at random
and then to all of their property
confiscated with no warning the lucky
ones were sent into exile the unlucky
ones they were executed executions under
Caligula or worse than under any prior
Emperor executioner's were instructed to
keep people alive as long as possible
slowly torturing them to death over
several days relatives they were forced
to watch these displays in some cases
parents were summoned to see their
children murdered unable to do anything
but smile and cheer best the mad emperor
have them killed as well just as he had
on Capri had seemed Caligula still loved
to watch people suffer yet gory as this
was it wasn't quite as bad as you might
believe
while Tiberius arranged to have rivals
assassinated as far away as Syria
Caligula basically forgot about anyone
he wasn't face to face with his treason
trials might have left Rome streets
flowing with blood but the rest of the
our continued to function as normal and
then in 1839 at the height of his reign
of terror Caligula finally met the woman
of his dreams
Malone EEOC's onea was a woman as
immoral and lacking in empathy as a
husband older than Caligula and
dedicated to nothing more than
self-indulgence she managed to win the
young despots heart although few records
of Maloney survived we do know that she
bought Caligula a daughter and that the
emperor names our Juliet reseller after
his dead sister we also know that
Caligula's messed-up way of showing
affection for his wife was to teasingly
remind her that he could have her
tortured and killed whenever he wanted
to over all then could they give up
reached the second anniversary of his
illness in a good place which is another
way of saying everyone else reached it
in a really terrible place where they
feared constantly for their lives as
October rolls around the Emperor felt
secure enough to turn his back on Romans
head off to the frontier to do some of
conquering but Caligula had misjudged
just how cowed by him his opponents were
with the madman out of the picture his
victims in the Senate and the Praetorian
Guard began to whisper to one another
about finding a new Emperor Caligula
didn't know about it but his short reign
it was nearly over is interesting to
wonder how Caligula must have felt
returning to the frontier where he'd
been raised no longer a toy soldier but
a conquering Emperor at least that's one
way of looking at it
mysamma counts Caligula spent his time
along the Rhine putting down a German
revolt and invading Gaul on the other
hands different accounts make it sound
like the toy soldier hadn't really grown
up at all one version has it that
Caligula paid soldiers to dress up like
Germans and staged an attack so that he
could defeat them and appear a hero
when actual Germans attacked shortly
after the Emperor ran away what's not in
dispute is that by ad 40 Caligula had
decided to invade Britain now that
signed Britannica was strange damp
Ireland's not yet under the roman heel
so conquering us would boost Caligula's
prestige accordingly Caligula wrote
north with 200,000 men up the cliffs of
Gaul facing the English Channel once
then he told his men to prepare for a
great victory and then had them go down
to the beaches and collect seashells
declaring these were spoils of a great
victory over the sea Caligula turned
around
and headed back to Rome back in the
Eternal City the conspiracy against the
Emperor was growing it was feds in part
by Caligula's believed that he was
literally a god he claimed to
communicate with Jupiter and ordered
statues of himself be placed in every
temple of the Empire when the news
reached Adair it very nearly caused an
armed uprising it was only thanks to
Herod grippers diplomatic skills that
Caligula waived the rule for Judean
temples and averted civil war but this
last flash of sanity was not enough to
save an emperor already so far gone On
January the 24th 41 ad the anti Caligula
faction they made their move outside the
Palatine Games units led by Casius
Correa waited until Caligula was coming
out and then surrounded him and stabbed
him to death before the alarm could be
raised they marched straight to the
house where Melania and the emperor's
baby daughter lived and killed them both
for a moment on that febrile day it
really looked like Rome's entire system
of Emperor's was about to collapse that
the Senate might seize the day and
restore the Republic but no Casias
career and his men instead tracked down
Caligula's uncle the doddering old
Claudius and him declared Emperor the
guard may have been ready to kill
Caligula but they weren't ready to kill
the system that had created him the
failure of their nerves that day would
result in another Caligula thirteen
years down the line in Emperor Nero that
wins a day in 41 ad though all the
carnage Nero would unleash was still a
long way away instead the Senate focused
on purging the virus of Caligula from
the Empire statues of the now dead
Emperor was smashed his name was
scrubbed from monuments one like the
fictitious telling is that the army even
tracked down and killed
Caligula's horse before Claudius had
established himself on the throne
Caligula was gone almost wiped from
Roman history the people wanted no more
reminders of them mad tyrants so why do
we remember him today
why is Caligula one of the few Roman
emperors nearly everyone can name what
part of it is doubtless entertainment
value even if the story about making his
horse a consul is untrue that's still
amusing that part of it may also be that
Caligula serves as a warning from
history before he took the throne
Caligula was a quiet nobody when he was
made an emperor all he seemingly wanted
to do was please the people the old
phrase has it that absolute power
corrupts
absolutely in the life of Caligula we
can see that this is true we all like to
believe that a good man could rule us
all justly and wisely but Caligula's
biography it suggests otherwise
it suggests that almost anyone can
become a monster perhaps even URI in the
end
Caligula may have only ruled Rome for a
mere four years but his deranged actions
during that time have ensured his name
will live on in infamy so I really hope
you enjoyed that video if you did please
do hit that like button below and don't
forget to subscribe for videos several
days a week I think we're up to four a
week now so hit that subscribe button
and the notification bell if you want to
learn about them also why not check out
my other channel called top 10s that is
linked to below and as always thank you
for watching